[Music]
foreign there you are watching The Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the observer's
chief leader writer Sonia soda and The
Economist for the article Ali Mirage
great to see both of you so as ever
let's head to the front pages uh
starting with the times which has the
arrival of President Biden in Belfast
for the 25th anniversary of the good
fried agreement with the president
saying peace is his top priority
the eye has news of a bleak economic
forecast for the UK from the
international monetary fund which is
predicting the country will see the
weakest growth of any G7 Nation the
guardian leads with the sacking of the
CBI director General Tony danker over
allegations about his behavior at work
claims that he is denied Daily Mail
claims an exclusive with a story that a
leader of England striking Junior
doctors has gone on holiday what his
colleagues are on the picket line
that's also the lead for the telegraph
Union boss on the holiday as doctors
walk out their headline
the Metro carriers statistics showing
that a mobile phone is stolen in London
every six minutes
the express says the bosses of Wimbledon
have been accused of handing Vladimir
Putin a win by allowing Russian tennis
players to compete at this year's
tournament
the Ft has a story involving the
financial consultancy firm ey better
known as Ernst Young and the star
Ponders the prospect of AI football
managers top marks for the headline robo
klopp
well a reminder by scanning the QR codes
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out those front pages
while you watch us so let's head
straight to Our Guest then Sonia soda
and Ali mirajenda so many of the times
with Joe Biden on the front page are
pieces priority he says not surprisingly
we know he's a great supporter of the
Good Friday agreement but something of a
family affair for him arriving with his
sister Valerie his son uh Hunter as well
departing off in the Beast obviously but
you know it's it's about Northern
Ireland and about the homecoming to to
Ireland to The Republic as well for him
okay that's right it's very much a visit
with twin purposes it's his first state
visit as president to Ireland and
obviously he's an American president
with Irish REITs he's going to be
conducting some visits with a sort of
extended uh distant family members while
he's in Ireland he's going to be
visiting uh the birthplace carlingford
of I think it's his great great
grandfather but don't quote me on that
please
um but it's obviously a huge visit as
well coming out on the 25th anniversary
of the Good Friday agreement and at a
time when storming the storm assembly
still isn't sitting hasn't been sitting
for many months now uh when the dup put
a stop to power sharing because they
were unhappy with the terms of uh brexit
um and you know a deal has just been
passed um around kind of brexit and um
uh you know a deal that that we hope can
continue uh the avoiding the need for a
hard border on the island of Ireland
which is so critical to Main
entertaining the stability of the Good
Friday agreement that was signed 25
years ago so it's a really it's a hugely
symbolic visit
um I think it'd be very important to
people on both sides of the Border in
Ireland
um but I think also you've got to have
realistic expectations for it and that's
what Tony Blair has been warning about
in the last couple of days he says it's
a really important visit but we
shouldn't kind of expect Magic from this
um you know it's not like Biden being
there and putting pressure on the dup is
suddenly going to magically end up in um
you know in the dep agreeing to go back
to table and resurrect storm and we
don't think anyway
yes I think it's his great grandfather
in terms of County louth and carlingford
Castle James Finnegan and his great
great uh grandfather uh in terms of um
County mayor as well uh the uh the
blewitz of County Mayo and certainly Joe
Blewett a third cousin of Mr Biden
saying there's a great buzz in the area
ahead of the president's arrival and the
great great grandfather Edward Blewett
sold 27
000 bricks to a cathedral where Mr Biden
will be speaking on Friday in 1827 which
helped him to afford to buy tickets for
himself and his family to sell to
America decades later in 1851 so some
lovely family tales for him but the
bottom line I suppose for Northern
Ireland uh Ali is it's a sense of
disappointment he was supposed to go and
speak to the Northern Ireland assembly
Stormont was supposed to be back up and
running it is not you know it's all been
scaled back a bit hasn't it
yes well that's true to a degree but
then storm it's not up and running for a
very simple reason which is the dup
won't play ball and go back into a power
sharing government and the frankly the
dup had been on the wrong side of the
argument for the last 25 years they
opposed the Good Friday agreement they
voted for brexit heaven knows only why
because what were they thinking there
would have to be a border somewhere that
border of those are either going to be
on the island of Ireland or it's going
to be in the Irish sea and it ended up
being in the IRSC and they felt like
second-class citizens so heaven knows
what they were thinking when they voted
for it I mean if you remember at the
time both Tony Blair and John Major went
to Northern Ireland to point out this
border issue back in 2016. so the dup
have got to like come clean and explain
what on Earth they were thinking at the
time they had a chance to redeem
themselves on this Windsor framework
where again they're betting down but the
problem for the dep I think is they were
on the risk of becoming increasingly
irrelevant over time you you now have a
situation where Shin Fein and this was
never expected would be the largest
party you're going to have a shin Fein
first Minister you've got optically the
dup playing second fiddle and the dup is
going to go into utter irrelevance
unless it actually steps up and does
what's right for the people of Northern
Ireland for all the people of Northern
Ireland which is get back into Power
sharing because the last thing we want
and this is why this uh this this uh
thing that we're we're looking at now 25
years this Historic Landmark is so
important because no one wants to go
back to 30 years of the troubles where
3600 people lost their lives including
in the Omer bombing in 1998 when 29
people died which is the bomb that went
too far no one wants that so the dup
needs to step up and Blair's right and
Sonia has mentioned it Tony Blair's
right the U.S president cannot cannot
force people to do things they can
cajole and if you remember back 25 years
ago when the Good Friday shine Senator
George Mitchell who chaired the talks
almost acted like the Midwife at the
birth of this agreement and you had big
leaders at the time David Trimble John
Hume Adams McGinnis all of them and that
agreement gave each party just enough to
live with no one was completely happy
but that's what leadership is about and
at the moment we're not seeing that same
leadership from the dup it's time to
step up okay well the dup will be among
those uh five main political parties to
meet Joe Biden tomorrow there will not
be a formal group meeting we are told
that's what the White House said this
evening a bilateral too with Rishi sunak
and then the speech obviously at Ulster
University so lots more coverage of that
tomorrow let's move on to what's uh
happening now and for the next couple of
days as well um Sonia the junior doctors
strike it comes after a bank holiday
weekend as well adds compounds if you
like the difficulties and we're hearing
already coverage of the night shifts
could be difficult keeping patients safe
amid these days of strikes
yeah that's right so um this is a really
significant strike I think it's the
longest consecutive strike that we've
seen so far in the Health Service four
days it comes after a three-day bank
holiday weekend sandwiched in between
two weekends that sort of nine days of
the NHS without kind of proper Medical
cover and it really does seem you know
we've talked about the sort of the
standoff between the government and the
unions in other areas of the Health
Service in other areas of the public
sector like with teachers it really does
seem to be a real sticking point here so
you've got the BMA asking for 35 pay
rise that's actually much higher than
nurses their argument would be well um
Junior doctors it's it's highly skilled
work and and our members just aren't
paid enough
um they've certainly seen a real terms
fine in pay over the last 12 years and
then you've got the government on the
other side saying well 35 is just
ridiculous you know we we we need the
BMA to come down in order to start talks
and I think think a lot of people might
be like well where's you know 35 might
seem high particularly when you consider
the nurses are asking for 19 but you
know where's the government's
counteroffer this is hugely disruptive
for the NHS
um there's going to be many many
operations
um examples of elective care canceled
these few days lots of people are going
to be really concerned about that people
who waited months for operations now
being told that they're going to have to
wait even longer and as The Clinical
Director of the NHS Stephen Powers has
said today this is not going to you know
this isn't disruption that's just going
to last for four days or even just the
nine days of the two weekends on either
side
um you know this is going to cause
knock-on impacts the NHS for weeks and
weeks and weeks so I think it's just
more Grim news really for patients
um you know obviously you've got NHS
staff who are saying we need we can't be
taking a real terms pay cut we we need
to see pay uh restored to where it was
and you know it sort of feels like it's
patience caught between the middle of
this fight between the government and
medical staff well the government of
course says it's unaffordable take a
look at the front page of the eye
possibly you get the small justification
for that more growth more tax receipts
more treasury funds for public services
uh it doesn't look like that's going to
happen for the UK which will be the IMF
said today the worst performing of the
G7 Nations Ali yeah
yeah I mean look I've always thought to
Anna that we were getting a little bit
ahead of ourselves within the office for
Budget responsibility is saying that by
the end of the year inflation is going
to be down at 2.9 I mean I'm not holding
my breath on that at all it's still 10.4
at the moment interest rates are 4.25
the bank of England's got a serious job
to do just get that inflation down and
it's remaining stubbornly High part of
the reason for that is because we have a
very tight labor market there are skill
shortages all over the place labor costs
is are going up is very very difficult
for uh employers to hire people at the
moment so this is not going to be an
easy time at all and in the meantime
you've got the NHS doctors and by the
way I defer to no one in my respect for
the NHS my mother was an NHS doctor for
40 years but 35 is just not realistic
the nurses started at 19. that was also
not realistic at all I understand why
doctors want a decent pay rise they're
saying that they've had a 25 percent uh
real term is pay cut in the last 15
years of course inflation at 10.4 of
course they want a decent pay rise but
35 is completely unaffordable we've got
over 2 trillion of public debt we spent
400 billion on covid we just can't
afford it people have to realize that if
they want that kind of pay they're going
to have to be Cuts made elsewhere where
are those cuts going to be made
education sector the teachers want pay
Rises the defense sector we've got a war
going on in Eastern Europe so where is
this money going to come from unless you
tax people even higher and the tax top
tax rate is now affecting people at 125
Grand as well so the taxes have also
gone up and when we wanted to also
increase National Insurance by 1.25
everyone was having a hissy fit about it
so we've got to be realistic in this
country do we want scandinating
Scandinavian style Health Care at
American levels of Taxation you can't
have both we need to have a proper
public discourse about what we want to
pay for public services and also how we
reform them and credit to the labor
party on this by the way at least West
Street in the shadow Health secretary is
saying that there needs to be NHS reform
we spend loads of money on the NHS it's
not that we do not spend a fair
proportion compared to other nations we
do but we still have very poor outcomes
so it's not just about pay it's also
about public sector reform as well